au mois d'avril une vidéo devient virale
sur les réseaux sociaux en côte d'ivoire
on y voit une femme suspendue au dessus
du vide tenu par un homme qu'on devine
être son conjoint et qui lui crie dessus
la scène est filmée par une voisine de
l'immeuble d'en face au bout de quelques
secondes la femme tondue troisième étage
par chance sa chute est ralentie par
l'auvent en toile d'un étage inférieur
elle n'est pas la seule dans ce cas 70%
des ivoiriennes seraient battus selon le
rapport d'une ong locale à l'image de
cette femme qui a préféré garder
l'anonymat
nous l'appellerons nadia elle s'est
réfugiée chez sa soeur car battue par
son mari depuis le début de leur union
ils l'apprécient pas qu'elle lui demande
de l'argent afin de marquer ça que j'ai
vu on doit préparer à l'agent de la
nourriture et je n'ai pas la jungle
alors tu n'avais pas l'âge figé si si
au début je faisais pas un patient ainsi
à deux pas de lui si j'insiste aimé gif
maintenant que je suis je suis déjà à
betty la jeune humain peut louer vous
nous parler d'argent souvent la fin du
mois l'effet du mois convives est
souvent un pays qui met battait mais
profil de mal à la cenap à tout moment
le mari de nadia et comme l enseignant
il est au chômage technique depuis la
fermeture des écoles
le couple le manque de revenus et
bascule progressivement dans la
précarité
fait aggravant le mari de nadia boîte
tous les soirs l'alcoolisme énième
facteur de violence dans un
environnement déjà difficiles depuis le
début de la crise du coronavirus les
associations offrent une oreille
attentive aux femmes qui subissent des
violences domestiques
car au commissariat les plaintes
aboutissent rarement pour la police
les problèmes de violence conjugale
doivent se régler dans le cercle
familial
une fois même il est tentant de le meux
battait puis à nos voisins que venu j'ai
vu intervenu et voisins tu vois la tuer
et les smartphones s'il a tué pourquoi
donc cette donnée leur entrée chez eux
et ça fait que quand il fait ça personne
ne nous approcher quand il va venir
on va donc le fois ensemble il peut il
changer vraiment beaucoup lui au siège
de l'om j'ai fait mon action dans le
quartier d'abobo
la présidente de l'organisation reçoit
une victime que l'on appellera marina
le mari de mme arena vient d'être mis au
chômage technique par son employeur un
retour au domicile contre 1 qui
occasionne chez marina une grande
angoisse rester confiné avec son mari
c'est le risque
chaque jour de recevoir des coups d'une
grande violence au sein de
l'organisation pouvant avoir de
personnes nous des personnes dans le
pire des cas trois personnes par mois
pour le mois de mars aux allemands on a
eu six personnes pour le mois d'avril
qui vient de faire lui mandat vue qui
vient défini nous avons vu personne en
deux mois nous sommes à quatorze le mois
de mai vient de commencer
les associations sont donc leur cours
principal pour ces victimes des victimes
toujours plus nombreuses depuis le début
de la crise